a mãe da gente gosta de escravizar a
gente né O cara tá saindo de casa já
andou dois quarteirão aí o cara escuta a
mãe gritar eu
i doido doido eu vinha correndo com
tudo que foi mãe que foi mãe ô meu filho
pega belin um copo deágua PR mim mãe
pela amor de deus eu pensava que a casa
tava pegando fogo mano agora era ruim eu
também me vingava dela ei mãe mãe mãe
vem aqui pelo amor de Deus mãe é o gente
mãe vem correndo pelo amor de Deus meu
Deus do céu que foi meu filho meu Deus
que foi meu Deus apaga bem a luz do
quarto para mim mãe moleque safado sem
vergonha tu me tirou de bem dali do meu
quarto para me vir apagar ai ai mãe ai
mãe é que aara quetinha não queria me
mexer não mane